c'est une région réputée pour son temps
pluvieux est de plus en plus pour ses
grands réservoirs de pétrole
le point d'arrivée du pipeline trans
martin la famille roy plus mental habite
tout près et sans surprise le projet
d'agrandissement de l'est au duc est un
sujet de discussion fréquents autour de
la table quand on profite beaucoup du
littoral de l'océan puis tous appuyé
l'outil qui va avoir comme trois fois
plus de trafic avec les bateaux
matile l'aîné avait voté pour le parti
de justin trudeau en 2015 stratégie
ouais pourquoi pas parce que j'ai été
déçu ici on veut un parti qui va mettre
la question environnementale vraiment à
l'avant-plan paravent l'environnement
c'est le parti vert qui s'intéresse plus
à celle parti npd aussi je trouve que
ils ont aussi une bonne alternative pour
l'environnement
au débat local des candidats le libéral
terry beach qui représente la
circonscription depuis quatre ans se
fait interpeller sur la question du
pipeline il est dans une position
précaire car si son parti a approuvé le
projet lui a voté contre
l'agrandissement
j'ai prouvé aux résidents de la région
que je pouvais défendre leurs intérêts
dit il si c'était les critiques ont
vaincu j'aime beaucoup monsieur bij
il est très honnête et très dévoué vous
voyez ici à hilali a les réservoirs
le candidat vedette des néo-démocrates
qui très connu dans la région ne pense
pas que terry beach puis se dissocie des
décisions de son parti monsieur je peux
dire tout ce qu'il veut que qu'il est
content que ça pour le contre mais sans
étiquette c'est les bars etc les
libéraux qui pousse ce pipeline c'est
aussi ce que croient les rois plus
mental l'espère un gouvernement
minoritaire
ben j'aimerais mieux voir un mineur tard
pour que le npd où les pères qui
prendrait plus d'ampleur au parlement
pourrait un peu influencé les décisions
mais l'idée d'une coalition formel entre
le npd et les libéraux ne me réjouis pas
qu on dirait qu'une alliance formelle
entre les deux parties feraient en sorte
que les reins des lignes tracées très
très clair très rigide qui serait fait
mieux vaut dit elle que les partis
d'opposition appuie les décisions du
gouvernement au cas par cas si leur
enceinte et radio canada